yeah a lot of excitement brady a lot of
excitement
because particle physics is still in the
game it hasn't died
it's amazing isn't it it's it's a bit
like waiting for buses
i was thinking about this the other day
you know you're waiting for a bus
and then all of a sudden three come
along at once yeah we were all worried
there was there was no new particle
physics to be found there was no new
particles we'd found everything that was
going to be found
we're waiting for a new particle and
then all of a sudden the bbc announces
at least two there are sort of
tantalising hints of some really
exciting new physics
um from two experiments recent sort of
announcements from two experiments one
of them's at cern
it's um the lhcb experiment
and you might recall we've been to the
lhc and we saw
the atlas detector and we saw the cms
detector they're called general purpose
detectors these huge
fantastic pieces of kit which discovered
the higgs
there are two more key detectors on the
lhc
ring one is called alice and but there's
another one
lhcb so the real excitement the real
excitement is coming from
the experiment coming from fermilab
where they've been looking at the
magnetic moment of the of the muon
lhcb is is a high precision detector
that's looking for very
fine events that might not occur very
often
but by searching in particular for
particular types of decay
then they've got a way of testing the
standard model of particle physics very
accurately
and it's through there that this
potential new discovery has
emerged what they did was they if you
remember at the lhc they fire protons
around in opposite directions and then
they collide them and they collide them
here in
in the lhcb detector they're looking for
the decay
of a particular type of meson
a meson is a combination of two quarks a
quark and an
antiquark and they're looking for a
meson called a b meson which has got a b
quark in it that we've got these three
generations
of of quarks and the b meson
also called the bottom of beauty is the
b quark is
often associated with the top quark you
and i are made up of the up and down
quarks
in fact everywhere around us here all
that we're re everything around here is
made up of up and down quarks
so these b quarks are very rare and they
decay rapidly
they form in these mesons and they decay
such that when they decay they decay to
another quark which is called an s
quark this is what the particular route
they're looking for a strange quark
and as they do so they decay producing
two leptons what are the electrons are
what you and i are made of electron is
an example of an electron of a lepton
but there's another key lepton called
the muon
and the muon is is going to be the star
of the show in particular
the number of times the b quark
decays either into electrons
and a positron or muons and it's
anti-particle and the the key thing that
it's trying to measure
here is the relative distribution of
these like
how many times does this process the
decay of this b
meson go into the electrons compared to
how many times does it go into the muons
and there's a very important principle
from the standard model called lepton
universality
and just this idea of universality
suggests that there's a common theme
between the various leptons and in fact
the belief is
that you should produce electrons just
as often as you produce the muons
so that if you can detect enough of
these decays
then you'll find half of them the time
they're electrons and half of the time
they're muons
well about uh a decade or so ago
there were experiments which suggested
this wasn't quite working out
that actually they were producing muons
at a
a slower rate than they were producing
the electrons
whereas you would have expected them to
be at the same rate and so
what they have done this quite
remarkable
team of working at the lhcb is they've
been assembling data from 2012
in fact i think maybe even earlier but
certainly 2012
onwards looking at all the decays
of these b mesons into what are called k
masons but basically it's the
bottom quark decay or the beauty quark
decaying to the strange
and looking at the output in terms of
number of electrons and number of muons
you would expect in sound processes
that you would decay just as equally in
terms into electrons as you would into
muons there's no there's no preference
there
because the couplings are the same
everything's just working at the same
strength
but that's not what seems to be
happening there seems to be a preference
for
for electrons the ratio of the number of
times you decay to the muon divided by
the
number of times you decay to the
electron isn't one
but it's about 0.8 so it's decaying to
the muon
far less often than it's decaying to the
electron
and an interpretation of that is that
maybe there's another particle
playing a role in this that we haven't
detected
that's played no major role in anything
else we've seen
but it's actually stopping the muon
somehow
from being from from it decaying to the
muon it's allowing the electron route to
go through but somehow it's
stopping the muon and so it's
there's been a lot of work on this type
of thing for many years
and there's a number of particles out
there which have been suggested as
possible ways of explaining this and
probably the most
common one that people have thought of
is called a leptoquark
leptons and quarks we usually think of
as totally separate particles but a
lepto
kind of is a new particle which brings
them together
and and it has properties of both
leptons and quarks
so it can feel the strong force as well
as just feeling the the
the weak force that the an
electromagnetic force that
that the quarks the electrons feel
and so i think there's going to be a lot
of interest in the possibility that this
process is now taking place so there's
this new particle
existing for a very short period of time
that then decays
into quarks and leptons and it's in such
a way that it's preventing
the b the beauty quark from decaying
into the muon as often as it decays into
the
electron why does it have to be a
particle why can't it just be that
nature
favors the electron root or something
like that it's a very good question
and in fact the standard model seems to
suggest
that it should go evenly in both
directions
so if it's favoring one clearly favoring
one over the other
we're assuming that the experiment is is
correct and is picking up
all the new ones that are being created
then
it's hard to do it within the standard
model itself
so now so then what do you do and it's
just that the easiest thing to try and
come up with is another particle one
thing i should mention
is perhaps it gets a little bit
technical but it's a boson
we have our fermions the stuff that you
and i are made of
the matter in the universe is made up of
fermions things with spin half
but these are effectively bosons which
are force carriers
so the photon has a spin one
the graviton has a spin too and this
is this has got a an integer spin it's a
boson and so
it actually also acts as a force so
it could be that this is in the news you
might have heard you know they talk
about a fifth force
and this is acting as that fifth force
but it's
hard to reconcile it simply within the
standard model and so you have to come
up with
something and if you've got your
favorite candidate that you can think of
that might be some fluid or then bring
it to the table in fact there are many
candidates i mentioned the leptor quarks
some people think of a particle called a
z-prime particle this is just the
z-particle
but very massive said particle and then
there's another called
vector vector quarks which are sort of
there's a whole series of them
so the second boss that came brown is
also
quite remarkable i mean this is the g
minus two muon experiment
so what the muon is is like the the
electrons heavier cousin it's
essentially very like the electron in
every sense and but it's heavier it's
about 200 times heavier than
the than the electron and just like the
electron it has what's called a magnetic
moment
this basically just is is is it's a
little bit of sort of intrinsic
magnetism
before we describe it let's just let me
just give you a little bit of background
of
this experiment which is a ring
basically which is
50 feet across 15 meters it was
initially performed at the
brookhaven national laboratory on long
island
and then once they'd finished and done
its experiment they decided the people
involved in it decided they would like
to upgrade it and also
take it to somewhere where there's a
better source of new ones but to get it
from
long island to fermilab which is in
batavia illinois
rather than going over cross land it
went out down the north atlantic
up through down to sort of new orleans
up through the mississippi
river into the illinois river and then
got put on
around chicago area got put on a huge
huge
lorry and got taken up the highway to
fermilab
what this experiment does is again it
looks at the muon
if you didn't have sort of you know all
the corrections coming from quantum
field theory things like that
then the magnetic moment of the of the
muon like the electron it would be
two it would just be the the number two
that's related to the fact that it that
it uh
it has spin a half but the answer is not
exactly
two okay it's slightly bigger than two
the magnetic moment of the
of the of the moon is slightly bigger
than two and the reason is the reason
it's slightly bigger
is it comes from sort of quantum
corrections to that number so what
happens is is the muon
it can sort of shapeshift and the mu one
is a particle
that's got a charge and so it's got a
dipole
which means it acts like a little dipole
magnet
a bar magnet and if you if you move that
muon in a magnet in a circle in a
magnetic field
it will begin to wobble a bit like a
spinning top you know if you push a
spinning top down and let it go around
it just it doesn't keep at the same
height it sort of wobbles as it goes
around
and you can measure the frequency of
this wobble now the frequency of this
wobble
tells you about the strength of the
magnet that the dipole is
it's called the magnetic moment of the
dipole so this is what's being measured
okay
and the the strength of this dipole it
can
give off a a photon and then re-absorb
it and this will create a correction to
to the
you know the predictive value for the
for the magnetic moment that photon
itself can sort of shapeshift into an
electron positron pair
that can then be created and annihilate
become another photon which gets
reabsorbed
there are all these sort of quantum
corrections this cloud of quantum
corrections that can
affect the value for the uh for the
magnetic moment
then people sort of naturally said well
it's not just
electrons and quantum electrodynamics
that could be important
maybe w and z bosons might be important
maybe
they're popping in and out of existence
as well and so they started doing
calculations
based on the what's called the vacuum
fluctuations of these particles
and they modified this number it still
was
two 2.00223 but you had more digits
added on
and everything was fine until you reach
the seventh digit
the seventh decimal place because at
that point
you have to start including the effects
of quantum chromodynamics the quarks
that can exist and they they're formed
by
the electron or the muon it could be any
of these electrons and
the muon being much heavier is one that
is worth probing because it can create
these extra particles around it in the
vacuum fluctuations
the muon can lead to it
a photon will emerge a virtual photon
then decay and then from it comes a
quark antiquark pair which then
reconnects
to a photon and then it gets reabsorbed
by the mu and that's the process
but this quark antiquark pair you have
to be able to account for
and that's where the problem is what we
found in 2001
was that the theoretical expectation for
the for the magnetic moment was
different to the
to the observed prediction they
disagreed at the eighth decimal place
okay so the eighth decimal place when
you really start to probe these rare
processes
the numbers differed and so people at
the time got very excited about this
but of course it wasn't statistically
significant then i think it was around a
sort of three sigma results
okay and then you know not quite enough
to classes as
a genuine discovery in particle physics
but enough to get people excited
so the theory now is to try and
calculate that
and there are two approaches to these
calculations
for the quarks they they're called the
virtual hadron processors
and they differ now one of them differs
in a way which is consistent
with the observation of this experiment
which i'll now describe and the other
differs in a way which leaves it
inconsistent so
their value for g is inc is different
to the experimental value by 4.2
sigma and if you recall five sigma
difference between a theory and an
experimental
value would be a discovery 4.2 is pretty
good it's getting close
isn't it the experiment is this 50 feet
or 15 meters
for our european colleagues ring so
fermilab they can produce
high-energy muons they fire them into
the ring and they go around in a big
magnetic field and if you recall i said
that
because they've got a magnetic dipole
they begin to wobble
a muon's heavier 200 times heavier than
a
than an electron otherwise pretty much
identical
it doesn't want to stay there it lives
for about a millionth of a second
by which time it's circled around about
a few hundred times but it then decays
to an electron it produces an electron
and the electron gets detected in the
detectors surrounding the ring
and the muons are carrying on going
around and decaying and
by the by looking at the energy of the
electron that comes out and the
direction that it comes into the
detector you know about the wobble
and the wobble if you recall the wobble
of its sort of parent muon yes
exactly and that wobble tells me
directly about the muon magnetic moment
this g
that we're trying to get it's very hard
to calculate these these sort of
hydronic contributions to the magnetic
moment of the muon it's very difficult
to calculate
but people got better at doing the
calculations they started to zoom in on
an agreed value for for the sort of
standard
prediction and then of course we needed
a better experiment which could really
pin down what the observational result
was and they've done this now
for they've been doing this experiment
for the past
i don't know five five six years
and they've begun to they've now started
releasing their data they've released
the first six percent of their data
the key thing they're trying to do of
course is control the errors
reduce the systematics make sure they
understand and i
sadly i can't do that justice but that's
a remarkable
achievement that they've done so the
theory seems to have tightened up a bit
but also the experiment is as has now
tightened up as well
and now we've got over a four sigma
result which again is still not quite
enough for it to clusters of particle
physics discovery
but it's really starting to get
interesting now and it does seem that
it's sensitive to new physics
it was all done blind so that when they
released
the data all of the teams saw it for the
first time there was a key
thing a key frequency clock which was
they didn't know about
and that they were given that
information that then allowed them to
plug it into a
key formula to get what g is and they
found the number g that they got was the
same
as the number that they they'd got at
the brooklyn national laboratory
and if you remember what i've just said
that is 4.2 sigma away
from the theoretical prediction that
came from this international group of
of uh physicists who were working on the
theory behind it
and so there was this remarkable result
that's emerged
that suggests if it holds
that the theory is based on standard
model physics
the experiment is the experiment you
just do the measurement
and it's once again suggesting that
there's something else happening that
the muons
are being tilted a bit more because the
actually the theory result is slow is
smaller the value of g from theory is
smaller than the value of g from the
experiment
and so it means the magnetic effect is
larger in the experiment
so whatever is causing this change if it
is new physics
is causing the muon to have a slightly
larger internal magnetic field than it
otherwise would
and leptor quarks and other possible
candidates are out there
let me see if i've understood this
correctly
it sounds to me like in in
nature in physics there are particles
popping into and out of existence
spontaneously all the time like a sort
of a soup
yes and one way to detect that soup
to measure what's in it what vegetables
and carrots and sprouts and things are
in it
is to look at how that soup affects
muons
and so they've been doing really really
good experiments with muons
to see how they're being affected as
they travel through this soup
to get a better and better idea of
what's in the soup
perfect and now that they're getting
these measurements better and better
there's a new vegetable that they've
never seen before absolutely there's
this quantum soup that surrounds
all the particles now you can imagine
taking the particle out of the soup
right and that's what we do with our
first approximation in our calculations
we take the particle out of the suit we
do the calculation we make a prediction
okay but then we start putting the
particle in the soup right
and we see that the soup starts to
affect our results and
absolutely you're right if there's some
sort of i don't know alpha spaghetti
spaghetti floating around in there or
something it's going to affect your
results
and muons indeed because they're heavier
they're more
sensitive to that unexpected unknown
physics that's that's that could be out
there
then say the electron would have been
this is a really interesting
time first of all it's worth pointing
out at the beginning i mentioned this
high precision experiments
these deviations between the experiment
and the theoretical predictions are in
the eighth decimal place of the
calculation
and also there is another group i said
of these two theory groups
approaching this problem the theory
group that the experimental group have
aligned
with in in the sense of comparing their
results directly with
have had to incorporate experimental
data
into their analysis not not the
experiment of the g
minus two but other experimental data to
deal with this hadron
question the vacuum polarization of the
hadrons
the and they're the ones that have come
out with the very low number 4.2 sigma
away
we maybe shouldn't get ahead of
ourselves it might not be a new particle
right so what it could be is it could be
that the theory prediction is still not
right
and it's a really unusual state of
affairs now we actually have
there's been a rival paper which is
claims to have done the the theory
calculation in a different way
and gets a result that's more in line
with just with standard model physics
nothing fancy
but which is more in line with the
observed volume there is another group
of people a smaller group but that have
just simply used
qcd on a supercomputer they've just
looked at lattice q
euclidean lattice qcd it's called worked
on a supercomputer
no experimental input using the standard
model
and they have come out with the result
which is actually compatible with the
experiment
okay and so we are in this amazing
situation where
we have the two theory approaches this
this shows you how we
that science is not a single track to
get to
somewhere these two theory approaches
both trying to solve a problem
are coming in with numbers which are
inconsistent with each other
one of them is consistent with the
experiment
which was consistent with the original
experiment so it suggests the experiment
is okay
right if these two are consistent 20
years apart
sort of accepted result the one that
we're saying is different to the to the
observation
what they do is they they take a sort of
data-driven approach
they're worried about the effect of
these hadrons in the quantum soup
right so those are very difficult to
calculate
hadrons they're strongly coupled they're
all tied in with gluons in this sort of
gluey mesh it's
difficult quarks are a pain to deal with
right
this is difficult so rather than
actually try to calculate that because
it's too hard
they take input from other experiments
or this so it's a data-driven approach
say well
given what that experiment's showing
this probably suggests that this value
of this thing is about this
therefore we'll calculate the rest then
they get an answer for the magnetic
moment of the muon
that doesn't agree with experiments but
the other guys this bmw collaboration
they're called right
nothing to do with the cars named after
budapest marseille and uh
vuter pal i think the name of your city
is so this this bmw
correlation what they've done is they've
shoved everything into a computer a
really fancy spanking
super computer that literally puts all
those
quarks on and hadrons on a giant lattice
and does the brute force calculation
right
really really sophisticated something
that you could never have done
decades ago really powerful calculation
and they've done
and so they've done this calculation
they're getting something more in line
why don't we just think that the first
group are the one that got it right
that seems like the more obvious
solution yes
i mean it and and and quite a few people
think this will probably may turn out to
be correct which would be in some ways
sad if you're really looking for new
physics
which we know has to be there somewhere
we still don't know why they
we're certain about matter and not
antimatter we don't know what the dark
matter is we need some new physics it's
entirely
possible that there's some systematics
that aren't quite right in the
in the lattice calculation in the bmw
calculation but maybe not it's a really
really impressive calculation that those
guys have done or maybe the data-driven
calculation isn't right but even if the
data-driven calculation isn't right
there's something going on here because
they're using data
so it's like is there something we're
not understanding about
that part of the data and how we feed it
into this calculation it still suggests
smells that there's something we're not
understanding about fundamental physics
here
so either way whether the whoever's
right about the the prediction here
there's something going on that we don't
understand
it might not be the magnetic moment
experiment that that's
that's we're missing it might be
something else i think the fact that
we're seeing something at the lhcb
this muon this decay of the beauty quark
to muons far less than than it goes to
electrons
and then this g minus two also involving
the muons
is suggesting there's something going on
the muons the heavier leptons
are being affected by this by something
and so i'd i'd like to waver on the side
of saying there's something there
i think it's a new physics i i really do
and
so there is i mean look there are
reasons for
other reasons to expect new physics to
be just around the corner you know we
talk about
why is the higgs particle so light this
is a mystery that we don't understand
why is hex particles so light
new physics can explain it you know
there's things like what is dark matter
you know we know dark matter's out there
we need a particle to explain it where
is it
okay we there's there's another sort of
quirk which is that the the
um we like to think that all the
different coupling strengths of particle
physics will come together and unify
at some high energies and you need new
physics to make that happen so this this
beautiful elegance
so there's lots of reasons to expect
that new physics is just around the
corner it's why we built the lhc for
example
right so the fact that they had now and
this is why everyone was freaking out
because it was like it didn't seem like
there was any no experiment was showing
anything up except for this
this is finally pushing us in that
direction that maybe there is something
there
you just have to look in the right place
and that's really exciting
the day after the day after this
announcement of g minus 2
30 papers appeared on the archive
another 13 today
that paper the prl that has appeared
already has
36 citations after two days
it's just kind of through the roof now
of course there'll be
a thousand papers i'm exaggerating but
there'll be a lot of papers come out in
the next few days people ambulance
chasing explaining
what explains this this this new new
phenomena i mean we were
i was chatting to some collaborators
yesterday right and we weren't thinking
about the the muon experiment you know
the neon experiments at all we were just
thinking about trying to explain dark
energy and string theory
and then we had this particle in it that
i was a bit worried about how light this
particle was and what what it might
affect and we did some digging while we
were on teams obviously everyone's on
teams aren't they
and we actually came across a constraint
based on
neuromagnetic moments and i was like
well this could be a you know sort of
joking right but
you never know these two announcements
have obviously made a real celebrity of
the muon which which is a particle that
doesn't get a lot of love
i don't know much about muons i like the
new one why are you even harsh on the
view of
i think it's great you make it sound
like they're really unstable do they are
there muons in this room
on a permanent basis or are they kind of
uh sort of a transient visitor
they'll be if they're there they'll just
be trans yeah they're certainly not here
sort of on a permanent basis
and and they they were first detected by
cosmic rays
you know the cosmic rays is this we need
to do something on cosmic rays by the
way but the
cosmic rays the highest energy particles
we've got
hit the atmosphere and and produce all
fundamental particles that that
that are consistent with the e equals m
c squared
and the muon is one of them it decay it
decays in about a millionth of a second
so if they're popping up here
they're decaying very rapidly do you get
jealous that the experimentalists seem
to get all the headlines and the big
moments and the big stories
i'll behave i mean like a lot the
superstars of physics are all theorists
right
of course they are that's that's without
question
so so now i mean come on einstein new
and all these superstars
they're all theories certainly
experimentalists are just the
lumpers don't say that don't forget
allows you then to read off where the
particles have come from the particles
aren't affected
they then move out to a second set of
detectors
called the calorimeters and the
calorimeters actually stop the particles